in louisiana school-aged children now
make up the third
largest number of new covet infections
in the state more than
2 000 new cases were reported among
children ages 5 to 17
during one week in july overall the
state is seeing eight times more cases
than just four weeks ago
our lead national correspondent david
begno is at children's hospital new
orleans david good morning
good morning we're inside the pediatric
intensive care units the largest
hospital in louisiana for
peds there are two others but they have
more patients here than anywhere else
the youngest
is a 23 month old baby girl in the room
right behind our camera and behind me
is a 17 year old young man now with his
blessing and his mother's permission
we're going to tell you their story we
met them last night
in the emergency room
this is jacquez lee he has coveted he's
17
62 365 pounds
he's a high school football player what
are you struggling with
uh breathing major headaches
you know like
a coughing too when we got to his room
the nurse told us that he had been in
the emergency room waiting for more than
nine hours
hopefully soon he'll go up to a room i
know they're working on it they ended up
having to wait more than
14 hours to get him a bed in the icu
fatina watkins is his mother she told us
that he started feeling sick about seven
days ago
it started when we went out to eat at a
fast food restaurant
we sat down and we ate inside which we
shouldn't have did
miss watkins is fully vaccinated and her
son received his first dose of the
pfizer vaccine
three weeks ago i just thank god that i
did get
the first vaccination for him you know
because it could be way worse than what
it is now
for her being here is like reliving a
nightmare
two years ago her four-year-old daughter
rayne marie
was treated at this very same hospital
for rsv
and she died this is the largest
children's hospital in louisiana
the covet case right here among
pediatric patients has
jumped just in the last week what's the
current situation
situation is dire dr mark klein a
world-renowned
expert in infectious diseases is the
physician in chief here
on monday we had four hospitalized
patients with covid
today we have 17 including four in our
intensive care unit for children and one
in our newborn intensive care unit
what do you say to the folks who watch
this who say yeah but
kids are you know only slightly affected
this delta variant that we're seeing now
changes the game from my perspective the
children are more ill they require
higher levels of care
and sadly i think we're going to be
seeing more deaths over the coming weeks
are you scared no his mother told us
jacquez is a fighter having this virus
is very overwhelming so it's best to
take care of yourself and to be safe
because it's really not worth it
watching your loved ones suffer when it
could all could have been avoided
so i just checked jacquez is stable and
his condition is about the same as it
was last night when we met him and his
mom in the emergency room
he's supposed to go back to school here
in new orleans in the next two weeks but
his mom said given everything they're
going through right now
she is too worried to send him back to
school
so she said i'm going to keep him home
and we'll do remote learning
instead david wow our prayers are with
the family for sure thank you